I remember you were dying in my hands
scared to walk away if you were here
right now I'd probably let you down
dying in my hands scared to walk away if
you were here right now
if you were here right now
my eyes
[Music]
tonight
over here
[Music]
is it my fault that I try to fix all my
habits when I had it kept running around
in these circles trying to fix that [\h__\h]
it's tragic and I never asked you
thought about it that's my fault not
acting like you should make me get
something against it I [\h__\h] up and I'm
asking you to come and stay another day
another kiss and I can [\h__\h] it up in
another way what's the point I see
destruction in above and now it's
underway love it if you stay but I'm
selfish
[Music]
scared to walk away
foreign
hey there y'all that was beautiful this
is my friend Mufasa who handled all of
the camera work for that shoot thank you
so much Mufasa anytime of course Wicked
uh where can the good people find you on
social media uh Fuego Manson Instagram
YouTube and Facebook although nowadays
more so Instagram wicked cool well thank
you again so much for your help today
and of course gonna wait for next time
hey everyone hey friends I hope you
enjoyed that flow
um I found the moon gate Garden for the
first time just a couple months ago when
uh the Magnolias Were In Bloom and
literally my first thought was I need to
shoot a video here so glad I got the
opportunity and thank you so much to
ultra POI for sponsoring this video and
giving me that opportunity if you'd like
to grab a set of those uh orb POI Pros
that I was using in this video you can
do so by using the promo code drexfactor
with a zero instead of an O at checkout
over at ultrapoi.com that gets you a
discount on your order and it helps out
the channel so everybody wins once again
thank you to ultra POI for sponsoring
this video and making it possible
speaking of thank yous I also have to
offer up a thank you to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flowfests flow toys Power Terra
light toys juggling calling spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel That
is Becca becklenen thank you so very
much for your support for my channel my
work and my mission now this video would
not be possible word not for the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all so very much for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you
if you'd like to check out some of my
other flow videos I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourself today and I'll
see you in a new video real soon
peace